Cal Newport wrote a book called Deep
work he's a theoretical computer
scientist
um
he took quite seriously the the task of
allocating the hours in the day for that
kind of deep thinking and then the
mathematicians is theoretical computer
scientists on steroids so for your own
life and what you've observed
well let me ask the big question how to
think
how to think deeply
how to find the mental psychological
pragmatic space to really sit there and
think deeply
how do you do it in the moment you
remember what you really deeply thought
what
was it an accident was it deliberate
no it's deliberate because you know
um
first of all my first years
as a mathematician you know
uh I worked every day
weekends holidays doesn't matter
um
I didn't even question that so I would
feel something's missing if I
took a day off
and you know so it was just a kind of a
sustained effort the point is that still
the process is non-linear to go back to
what we discussed earlier that in other
words the way I see it is you just you
are making an effort to to bring all the
information into
Focus what you believe is correct and
you're playing with different
um
ways of connecting things
but it is a total Miracle when it when
suddenly there is inside strikes it is
not something that in my experience
could be predicted
or even anticipated you know or like
brought closer
there's a famous story about Einstein
that he used to you know go think think
and then go for a walk and like he would
whistle and sometimes so I remember the
first time I heard this story
this came to him when he was whistling
but in fact it's not this is how it
works in some sense that
you have to prepare for it but then the
moment it happens when you stop thinking
actually it's okay the moment of
Discovery is the moment when thinking
stops and you know you kind of you kind
of almost become that truth that you're
seeking but you cannot do it by Will in
some sense it's some it's kind of like
you know how in eastern tradition they
have this concept of Satori like in
Buddhism and Buddhism you have this
Satori which is enlightenment
and so the various reports of
Buddhist monks or Buddhist Masters who
have had experience Satori
but they say you can't
you can't uh do it by will you cannot
make it happen
if anything you have to relax to let it
come to you you know it's kind of like
that it's kind of like that so
I think that what matters
but you say how to think the point is
that we're talking about such an
esoteric area
is really esoteric area it's really
strange subject where you try to
to fit everything
in this very very stringent set of rules
those rules isn't it basically the the
pure the hardest manifestation of a
puzzle that we're all solving in
different other disciplines but this is
the the hardest puzzle yes and no
because there's just a different
for instance there is a different
Criterion for what constitutes progress
for instance physics
a lot of arguments they make they are
not rigors from mathematical perspective
it is kind of an intuitive argument we
think it is like this and this is
acceptable in the subject for a good
reason and on the so there is some play
it's more it's more like human activity
day to day activity like for instance if
we you and I discuss something you have
an idea and I have an idea and we argue
about it and something seems more
plausible
something seems less plausible and so we
may decide to take this point of view of
that point of view as a provisional sort
of like
point of view and go with it in Mad Max
it doesn't work this way you either
prove it or you don't and oftentimes
you get to the point where there is this
much you need to prove and it just it
just wouldn't wouldn't come to you and
you just don't see it and it can have it
can go on for months
super frustrating but without it it is
it is nothing kind of you know I would
love to hear your opinion uh to the
degree that you know it um of the proof
of Hermos theorem by Andrew Wiles which
seems to have this element
perhaps for years to the degree that you
know perhaps can you explain from
azler's theorem and what your thoughts
are in the process that Andrew Wells
took that seemed to at least for my sort
of romantic perspective seemed to be
very lonely yes
it's a lovely profession
and hopeless and and uh
and sort of the pro you put it really
nicely because it's it it feels like
there's a lot of moments where you feel
like you're close you feel like 19 is
done yeah and there is this one stubborn
thing
which just does not compute you know
doesn't happen and you're trying to find
that push for this last link and it
could take and nobody knows how long
it's going to take